how are you feeling I'm feeling good  pretty large yes look hey he's showing  off the bump for you that's his job you  guys ready is that was the nursery ready  is it super ready nothing else is ready  it's just we've we've been laughing  about this it's just it's much different  with our now two-year-old we were fully  ready for everything so like there was  just with this little dude like it's  just different having a tutor all now  you know you just don't think about as  much preparation for being pregnant with  a two-year-old it is much harder than I  expected you know I'm really tired so  like by the end of the day it's the last  thing on my mind is prepping the new  baby's room who's coming like it's  inevitable this baby is coming there's  no stopping it you know but no we're not